crois que la première fois j'ai ressenti
ce manque de nature c'est le retour d'un
long séjour à la campagne un moment des
collections avec la ville son rythme
effréné ces odeurs et ses bruits
je me suis
fait
ces longs et
beaux paysages qui se profile est devant
moi
se posait alors la question de savoir
est ce que j'allais rester
fallait que je revienne
dans un espace minéralisée ou le dernier
et végétales de ma rue avait été rasé
une année de palmiers
dont toutes petites bêtes avaient eu
raison de chance
l'été a été chaud
l'air transpiré de chaleur est remontée
des sols transpirer les murs il y avait
une tension vraiment inquiéter palpable
la température ne baissait pas ni
l'injure ni le jour ni la nuit et
je me disais
combien je regrette vraiment
2.2 sur
et donc du coup
j'ai voulu simplement
réfléchir à ceux
de déconnexion que nous si tu as toi
avion avec la nature est assez
simplement je me suis aperçu que c'était
assez compliqué
vivre en ville dans cette tension qui
pourrait y avoir en été
alors
effectivement
les températures pas et puis surtout
lors des faits pluie en fait les rues se
gonfler d'eau devenaient des ruisseaux
des rivières et des fleuves et je
comprenais pas qu'à un moment donné en
ville on ait réussi à contrôler la
nature l'astreindre à certains espaces
sans jamais pouvoir contrôler cette eau
qui circulait dans nos rues et qui
venait à manquer lors des saisons sèches
à l'époque je tiens un blog sur le
graphisme et je me dis ça serait
peut-être intéressant moi qui
connaissent aucune connaissance sur
internet de lancer un blog qui
référencerait l'ensemble de toutes les
initiatives qui sont nous mener dans la
ville pour réimplanter un peu de nature
mes premières recherches sont pas
forcément infarctus 20 fructueuse je
découvre que par exemple des sociétés
ont lancé des petits crayons papier qui
en fin de vie peuvent être plantés dans
un pot et donner vie à une petite plante
ou alors
le jardin de poche que l'on met dans la
cuisine pour faire pousser des aromates
et puis pour ceux qui ont pas forcément
la main verte des petits pots avec des
curseurs et des petits nounours qui
sortent la tête des clots fini à manquer
toutes ces initiatives sont intéressants
peuvent répondre à un besoin personnel
mais la question que je me posais c'est
qu'en est-il à l'échelle de la ville
là on est en 2011 2013 2015 on arrive en
le coc vide ariz tout s'arrête
active se réactive dans ma tête cette
volonté de comprendre pourquoi on avance
oui si doucement dans la réimplantation
de cette nature en ville
alors je lance une newsletter en me
disant qu'après tout le l'élément blog
pas forcément approprié à ma cible et
donc du coup je renvoie toutes les deux
semaines à ceux qui veulent l'entendre
les petites news que j'ai découvert
bonjour à tous je m'appelle hicham
nakhla je suis si tu as un engagé alors
je voulais partager avec vous deux ou
trois éléments que j'ai identifié sur la
ville et qui pose aujourd'hui quelques
problématiques
la ville se réchauffe vous avez tous
marcher sur un parking est ressenti
cette chaleur qui se dégageait du sol
alors à l'échelle d'une ville c'est ce
qu'on appelle les îlots de chaleur
commence à se caractérise la chaleur est
emmagasinée dans les murs des immeubles
dans le béton dans le bitume des routes
des parkings et des trottoirs et ensuite
remonte
pour rafraîchir pour réchauffer
excusez-moi l'air de la ville et créer
une bulle de chaleur la température ne
baisse pas étant donné que l'air en
ville se refroidit beaucoup moins ville
qu'à la campagne on a pu constater au
même moment des différences de
température de 10 degrés
vous faire part d'une petite expérience
mais qui est plus en hiver cette fois-ci
l'hiver dernier je discutais avec un
agriculteur de la ville de valence dans
la drôme qui me disait que des arbres
fruitiers avait été impacté par le gel à
dix kilomètres du centre-ville quand ces
mêmes arbres n'avait pas du tout subi
les affres de la delà de l'hiver
donc ça c'est la vie qui se réchauffe la
ville qui se réchauffe on aurait
tendance à se réfugier dans la
climatisation c'est ce qu'on fait tous
li lété ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
en refroidissant en eaux intérieures on
réchauffe la ville la ville de phoenix
aux états unis a mené inutile dans ce
sens et s'est aperçu que la ville se
réchauffer de 1 à 2 degrés une fois que
la venue venez quand les climatiseurs
tourner à plein régime
ça c'est le premier point les identifier
le deuxième point dont je vous ai parlé
en introduction c'est cette eau qui
n'ont délai les rues alors vous avez pu
voir que depuis quelques années on sent
la multiplication des inondations on
pourrait se dire que c'est lié au
réchauffement climatique effectivement
il ya une accélération qui lie à ça
mais d'après mes recherches on
s'aperçoit que c'est vraiment dans leur
conception d'autres villes on à
imperméabiliser la ville ont rapidement
évacué ces trombes d'eau qui circulent
dans nos rues à l'extérieur de la ville
alors effectivement ça a pu
apporter une solution mais on a parfois
atteint des limites c'est à dire que ça
crée des saturation de réseau tout en
sachant que canalisations ne sont pas
extensibles donc saturation des réseaux
domestiques notamment les douches et les
toilettes qui se déversent dans les
cours d'eau mais également le transport
de polluants
issus des sites industriels
on s'aperçut quand même que la ville
en sus
pas forcément pour le bien-être de ses
habitants enfin en tout cas moi quand
j'entends ces deux problématiques je me
dis que là est quelque chose qui qui
colle pas forcément
aussi
j'ai ressenti je vous le disais
également dans mon intro ce ce manque de
nature ans pour moi savait pas un énorme
impact mais aujourd'hui ça a été
identifié comme étant un déficit de
nature
déficit de nature qui a des impacts sur
notre santé notamment
sur des pathologies comme les troubles
anxieux et dépressifs mais également sur
les maladies cardiovasculaires et
l'obésité
je voudrais m'arrêter sur un point
également
c'est
les enfants
ah les problèmes qui ont été soulevés
durant de confinement sur leur isolement
je fais partie de cette génération en
fait il ya eu la chance de pouvoir
courir dans de grands espaces
monter aux arbres construire des cabanes
sans forcément incliné dans la
superficie est inutile qui montre que
depuis 30 ans
90% de la surface sur laquelle peu
gravité un enfant sans la supervision de
ses parents a été réduite ce qui est un
impact évidemment sur nos modes de vie
mais également sur le mode de pensée
c'est à dire qu'on peut imaginer assez
simplement que si un enfant a peu de
contacts avec la nature et on sera
beaucoup moins sensibilisés et beaucoup
moins
attentifs aux problématiques
environnementales
climatique
continue donc sur cette notion
fin et je me dis vous avez tous petite
soeur
frère des enfants et vous avez pu voir
vraiment l'émerveillement tu peux avoir
un enfant lorsqu'on lui parle de tel et
tel animal du pingouin de l'ours polaire
ou par exemple désastre c'était
merveille mans je pense que la nature la
porte le priver de cette de cette chance
peut être à mon sens problématique or
j'avais trois solutions la première
solution c'est de me dire après tout je
vais continuer à lister l'ensemble de
ces problématiques et puis je vais aller
chercher les responsables comme on le
fait sur certains réseaux
et qui qui correspond pas forcément
à mon caractère
la deuxième motion c'est simplement se
dire après tout d'ici 2050 on devrait
être notre milliard d'habitants
70% de la population habitera en ville
finalement il ya rien à faire partons
tous à la campagne peut-être qu'on
pourrait trouver des solutions ou la
dernière option c'est se dire finalement
les problématiques sont identifiés il
suffit de ce baiser baissé pour le
ramasser et que ce serait assez
intéressant de se focaliser vraiment sur
les solutions
donc je vais aborder avec vous quelques
solutions on a parlé donc de cette peau
qui constituait la ville c'est-à-dire le
fait que la ville soit bitumée et
imperméable je propose qu'on débite eu
simplement des bitumes ans partout on
peut de plus en plus de villes ont comme
objectif de replacer le citadin au coeur
même de leur 2 lors de leur conception
en créant plus de zones piétonnes plus
de place pour les cyclistes donc
forcément peut-être beaucoup moins de
place pour la voiture donc on aura
énormément des espaces vides fumée comme
les parkings les routes on va pouvoir
des bitumes et est laissé à la terre
la possible et et de respirer de
transpirer et de rafraîchir et puis
plante on plante on plante on plante on
alors plan tombe des végétaux mais
également des arbres je m'arrête sur
l'arbre parce que pour moi c'est
l'élément clé de la végétalisation ville
ce qu'il faut savoir seulement et ça je
vais faire une petite parenthèse c'est
qu'aujourd'hui l'élément ab utilisait un
peu comme l'outil marketing de beaucoup
beaucoup dans celles beaucoup beaucoup
de marques pour vanter leurs produits
mega l'est également en vente et leur
engagement écologique et parfois j'ai
l'impression que c'est la solution
labeaume n'est pas la solution il peut
être un partenaire dans la solution on
pourrait apporter dans notre façon de
2 dans l'autre façon de considérer la
terre mais ce n'est sûrement pas la
solution donc je pense qu'il faut faire
être attentif au fait que c'est pas
parce que on va planter des arbres que
on va pouvoir compenser notre carbone
non je pense que l'art peut être une un
partenaire important mais qui va falloir
réfléchir à notre consommation et aux
ressources qu'on utilise je reviens à
l'arbre vous avez tous marcher sur un
parking est ressentie cette chaleur qui
monte du sol et puis vu une allée de
platanes tout de suite vous réfugier sur
cette année donc l'arbre nous apporte
l'ombre âge et ça inutile d'être
scientifique pour la prochaine à
percevoir les températures sont beaucoup
plus basses sous un arbre ça permet
également grâce à ses feuilles et
l'évapotranspiration
de rafraîchir
l'environnement puis à d'autres qualités
qui sont pas forcément connus notamment
sur le fait de filtrer les particules et
polluant
d'oxygène absorber le gaz carbonique
stabiliser les sols et drainer l'eau qui
a dans le sol
je vais vous donner quelques exemples
justement sur la ville qui se visualise
madrid capitale espagnole s'est donné
comme objectif de créer une ceinture
verte autour de sa ville de sa capitale
215 km en plantant des arbres en faisant
en sorte de créer des sentiers de
randonnée et des parcs pour les enfants
voilà type d'initiatives que je pense il
faudrait aussi
puis il ya la ville de philadelphie la
ville de philadelphie qui est une des
villes les plus pauvres des dix plus
grandes villes des états unis
philadelphie qui s'est donné comme
objectif de couvrir de 30% le territoire
de sa ville de couvert forestier
une étude a été menée en parallèle et on
s'est aperçu qu'on pourrait sauver plus
de 305 morts prématurées chaque année
donc on se dit qu'après tout on va
pouvoir rafraîchir la ville mais aussi
avoir un impact sur la santé de nos
citoyens
notre initiative qui est excellente dans
cette ville c'est que la cimenterie
philly pour permettre d'accélérer cette
plantation a distribué plus de 1000
arbres à ses habitants vous les aider à
planter donc voilà ça permet également
d'engager le citoyen dans la conception
même de la ville et enfin la ville
d'atlanta a affirmé dernièrement qu'elle
avait économisé 885 millions de dollars
en infrastructures de réseau pluvial en
plantant des arbres donc on s'aperçoit
que véritablement il ya des solutions
qui sont existantes qui ont été testées
et qui marche le dernier point ça va
être la vie
inondée donc là vous avez un exemple
typique de ce qu'on appelle une ville
éponge c'est à dire qu'on a le même
territoire qui a été pensé pour que
durant
saison de plus c'est un plus tôt c'est
une zone inondée avec des passerelles où
les habitants peuvent sillonner et puis
durant les saisons sèches c'est un parc
où les habitants
peuvent gravité peuvent baladés et puis
en même temps avoir ce contact avec la
nature avec différentes essences
d'arbres donc voilà c'est ce qu'on
appelle la ville éponge
pour conclure
j'aimerais juste vous dire
je suis yann urbanistes anarchique acte
simple citoyen qui a décidé à un moment
donné de s'intéresser à comment la ville
dans sa ville était conçu
il ya deux choses qui sont importants
pour le changement à mon sens c'est
l'émerveillement je pense que les
enfants sont inspirantes dans ce sens là
puisque prenez juste l'arbre si on sera
un peu sur cet élément là on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya des choses qui sont
complètement incroyable et puis
l'engagement c'est à dire ne pas laisser
la ville se faire
sans notre accord sans notre aval et
sans notre engagement voilà donc moi
j'ai décidé qu'à chaque bonne nouvelle
j'allais à diffuser et je vous invite à
chaque initiative
chivu dans ce sens-là de la diffuser à
trois personnes de votre entourage puis
à 3 personnes de votre entourage qui la
diffusera trois personnes de votre
entourage et ainsi de suite je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]